apple has been in the portable laptop
game for longer than i've been alive
with the powerbook 100 that was released
back in 1991
and over the years they've evolved into
what we know
as the macbook lineup every macbook
since 2008
has come with a beautiful unibody
aluminum chassis
which at the time was revolutionary but
it came
at a price for the past decade or maybe
even longer
apple's macbooks have been known for
being very expensive
compared to the competition over on the
windows side
which used to all come with plastic
bodies
and even though apple's macbooks clearly
had a leg up in terms of resale
value many people still chose to go with
cheap windows laptops and chromebooks
because they were simply much more
affordable
compared to apple's macbooks that would
start at at least a thousand dollars or
more
we even made a video explaining why
apple macbooks are so expensive
with the different reasons ranging from
having the best track pads out there
the best speakers out there better
microphones than other laptops
excellent displays and much more but
fast forward to today
and it's pretty clear to me that apple
has completely juked
or essentially tricked the entire laptop
market
and now they're beginning to
revolutionize it in a totally
unexpected way as they begin to eat up
the laptop market share
so let me explain how apple pulled it
off in 2012
dell decided to break away from the
plastic chain
and offer a laptop that would feature
premium build quality
in an attempt to compete with apple's
macbooks on the more expensive side
of the laptop market and that was of
course with the xps
13. this design used premium carbon
fiber materials
to get the weight below three pounds
while being impressively thin
and starting at a lower 999 dollar price
tag
than apple's 2011 macbook air which
started at a pretty high
15.99 but over the years dell and other
windows brands kept improving their
premium windows laptops
making them thinner lighter and more
powerful
even adding a thunderbolt 3 port on the
2016
dell xps but then apple did something
that shocked the world
they completely scrapped all of their
ports on the 2016 macbook pro
and went with a simple set of four
thunderbolt 3 ports
which sparked the rise of usbc which
eventually went mainstream
and if you haven't seen my video on
apple's usbc
master plan definitely check it out
because it's very eye-opening
but going back to the dell xps in 2018
they completely ditched the usb-a ports
and went with
thunderbolt 3 ports while at least still
keeping an sd card slot
now at this point something very
interesting began to happen
premium windows laptops started to catch
up to apple's macbooks in terms of the
pricing
especially with the 2019 dell xps which
got an
even more premium chassis and just last
year
we compared the latest dell xps 13 to
apple's
10th gen intel macbook pro and the
results were
very interesting a similarly spec'd xps
13 model
was only a hundred dollars cheaper than
the 1800
macbook pro and the xps had many
shortcomings
like having a much worse trackpad having
inferior speakers
a worse webcam much worse microphones
and only half the thunderbolt 3 ports so
at that point
apple's macbook pros didn't seem like
that bad of a deal after all
since many premium laptops with matching
specs
were already getting close to the same
price of the macbook pro
so the overpriced macbook narrative
started to die down a little bit
the only real issue that remained was
that apple's intel
macbook air was hugely flawed with
overheating
issues that caused the fans to spin up
really loud
and the performance was pretty terrible
forcing us to recommend apple's
1800 macbook pro if you really wanted a
great macbook
but then in november of 2020
everything changed apple revealed the
brand new m1 chip
that went into the macbook air the
macbook pro and
the mac mini this chip basically blew
everyone's minds including ours
especially since it allowed the
passively cooled macbook air
to obliterate the previous intel-based
air
almost matching up to the performance of
the m1
macbook pro for 300 more and not only
did it have
excellent performance but it came with
killer battery life compared to windows
laptops and it was priced at only 999
dollars
with it being on sale right now on
amazon for only 8.99
so for the first time ever we decided to
compare the m1 macbook air
to a fully loaded 16 inch macbook pro
for 38.99 and to our surprise
the m1 air outperformed it in terms of
multi-core performance
it almost matched up in terms of logic
pro music production
it actually destroyed the 16-inch for
xcode programming
it almost matched up for lightroom photo
editing
and it actually matched up or even
exceeded it
for some video editing tasks like atvc
stabilization and 10 bit 422
rendering this basically blew our minds
and at this point it was clear that
windows laptops were in
deep trouble at this point apple's 1300
m1 macbook pro was greatly outperforming
dell's even more expensive xps 13
options
while also getting much better battery
life
we also tested razer's brand new razer
book 13
which was actually more expensive at
sixteen hundred dollars
compared to a similarly spec fifteen
hundred dollar m1 macbook pro
and the m1 smoked it across the board
and then we compared the m1 macbook air
to microsoft's brand new surface laptop
4s
both the intel and amd models and the m1
basically destroyed them being a much
better value for the price
but the nail in the coffin was us
comparing the 999
m1 macbook air to lg's brand new
gram 14 laptop for 11.99
and the m1 was better in basically
everything
from performance to build quality and at
that point
i realized that apple had succeeded with
the first
phase of juking the windows laptop
market
by getting them to follow in their
footsteps by improving their materials
which led to laptop prices almost as
high as apple's macbooks
and out of nowhere apple swooped in with
the m1 chip
causing their lower end macbooks
especially the m1 macbook air
to outperform out value and
outlast the batteries of the windows
laptop competitors
all at the same time this is a massive
issue for the windows brands out there
because they don't currently have access
to high-end arm chips like apple does
so if they want to stay competitive they
need to lower the prices of their
laptops
and because apple juked them into using
higher and higher quality materials and
parts
they're kind of stuck in a box because
they're either going to have to accept
lower profit margins if they lower their
prices
or they're going to have to lower the
quality or the specs of their laptops
compared to their current models which
is going gonna cause
outrage within the laptop community and
that's probably why we've recently been
seeing many lifelong windows users
finally decide to switch over to the mac
all because
of the groundbreaking m1 chip and with
each day that
passes more and more software companies
are continuing to optimize their apps
for apple silicon like adobe which just
announced
native m1 apple silicon support for
premiere pro
media encoder and character animator and
get this
the m1 macbook pro is now twice as fast
as a windows
desktop pc with the best of the best rtx
3090 gpu in terms of scene edit
detection in premiere pro
but all of that was just the first phase
of apple
juking the laptop market so now let's
get into the second
future phase apple's m1x macbook pros
are getting released within the next
couple of months
and they're literally going to shock and
revolutionize
laptops forever unlike with the m1 max
apple is now going to be focusing on
maximizing performance
with the m1x chip and based on reports
from mark german
the most reliable apple leaker out there
the chip will come with 8
high performance cpu cores 2 efficiency
cores
and either 16 or 32 graphics cores
and based on my calculations it will
outperform
every laptop chip ever made in terms of
cpu performance
with a geekbench multi-core score of
over 14
000. on top of that we're expecting the
32 core gpu model
to score around 80 to 90 000 points in
the metal graphics test
performing around as well as an rtx 3060
gaming laptop
but keep in mind that the gpu in the m1x
is going to be fully
integrated into the soc package
providing extra benefits
due to the unified architecture but on
top of all of that
the m1x macbook pro is gonna once again
juke the premium windows laptop market
by bringing everyone's favorite ports
back
based on reliable reports from mark
german as well as leaked apple
schematics
apple is bringing back the sd card slot
the hdmi port
and the magsafe charging connector on
the m1x macbook pros
and meanwhile dell's brand new xps 13
is still stuck with two thunderbolt
ports and a micro sd card slot
so it's pretty obvious that they'll be
following in apple's footsteps again
to bring back some of those ports and
once these m1x macbook
pros are on the market they're gonna
shake up the entire industry
and cause windows laptop brands like
dell to scramble
trying to get their hands on arm-based
chips to throw into their laptops
so they can compete in terms of
performance and battery life
and that right there is gonna be the
laptop revolution
that apple masterminded now if you
totally disagree with my thoughts
then go ahead and comment your thoughts
down below but if you enjoyed the video
definitely click the circle above to
subscribe and check out one of those two
videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video